hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with our
1858 odds match between uh reverend john
owen and paul charles murphy if you're
only joining now uh in the paul morphy
saga or in this match we are currently
uh well during this match uh that is
only the second game that we're showing
uh
first uh reverend owen defeated morphy
using the owen defense
if you haven't seen that game i will put
a link to it in the description below
don't miss it it's quite the game
and then in the previous game morphy
played with the black pieces again
without his
f7 pawn and was able to win a quite uh
quite a spectacular game and now we have
another one morphe again with the black
pieces without his
f7 pawn let's see what happens here and
how will how will the match continue
and before we check out the match i
would just like to mention that agar
matarini is having
uh a chess quiz tomorrow on his twitch
channel so if you guys are interested in
you know chess
and quiz uh do check it out i will also
put a link to
it in the description below so let's uh
let's check it out uh owen with the
white pieces
again opens with e4 uh but in the
previous game
uh where morphe was playing uh with odds
uh went knight to c6 but here we have e6
so
sort of uh uh you know uh uh or odds
french
let's call it that uh we have d for d5
and
bishop to d3 by owen and now g6 so a
french with the g6 without the f7 pawn
very very interesting stuff so knight to
f3 and now
c5 striking in the center like if you
would uh
like you would in in a normal french and
now uh as
a blacks well pawn structure isn't
really
existent you could just play captures
captures and it would be very hard for
black to play this his king is already
wide open
the g6 pawn even creates additional
weaknesses with c4
castles you will get quite the edge here
but owen plays it
cool he plays c3 and morphe continues
development we have knight to c6
and owen castles queen to b6 by morphe
putting more pressure on the center here
and only now owen trades we have
captures captures and rook to e1 check
bishop to e7 and now owen goes in with
knight to g5
he's the uh basically playing playing
for tricks with
this knight to g5 move but it is very
interesting uh if you wanted to really
gain an edge then you go
d captures on c5 because the bishop is
pinned you cannot capture with the
bishop
and well it's just a nice free pawn b4
b5 is coming you'd have to go back with
the queen
because if you capture then b4 goes
after the queen queen d6 b5
and once you move the knight you now
white gains the
access to the e5 square or you can just
go bishop c4
and the position really just falls apart
you cannot capture because of queen
captures the bishop is still pinned
bishop to a3 is coming and it's going to
be
very very hard for black to play this
but okay owen knows what he's doing
he goes knight to g5 uh and here morphy
continues with knight to f6
just developing his pieces and here owen
starts a very very interesting attack he
starts with knight captures on h7
uh he weakens the g6 spawn uh and of
course he wants to capture it uh
if if you go for knight captures uh then
you've just removed
one one of the defenders from the king
and bishop captures is coming with
check when he's coming to h5 and uh well
black will fall fall apart very quickly
so instead morphe captures with the rook
which is uh well interesting as it also
will come with bishop captures here with
a double attack but then morphy plans to
shift the rook over to f7
uh to help with the defense and he
doesn't mind giving up a rook for two
pieces
so bishop captures and g6 with check
rook to f7
and now not capturing there's always
time to capture this
as they say you know the the threat is
always stronger than the execution
uh most of the times and uh just
continues with bishop to g5 now the
now everything is pinned here the bishop
cannot move the rook cannot move
uh morphy really really needs a move
here so he just continues development
bishop to g4 which is good because it
comes with an attack on the queen
hopefully later on you can maybe unpin
force white to capture if you manage to
bring the rook into the game then you're
gonna be okay because white
did sacrifice a piece for this attack uh
and here it's uh well
although it seems like there are a lot
of tactics here there really aren't for
example if you just uh
what can you do if you try something
like queen captures on g4
uh black can just capture because you
don't have rook captures on e7 the
knight here also defends that
if the knight wasn't there then maybe it
would be possible
also you could try rook captures on e7
something like this uh but now king
doesn't capture
so you can capture on g4 but rather
again this knight will capture
so this knight really makes it
problematic for owen to finish this game
quickly so instead after this bishop the
g4 attacking morpheus uh
owens queen queen to c2 uh and okay
morphe now needs to continue
king to f8 he and pins and now he says
okay now you either capture or i'm gonna
move my rook so here
here owen captures with bishop captures
king captures and
now h3 making some breeding room for the
king pushing back the bishop
bishop to h5 and only now that the
bishop moved uh you want to play queen
to h7 check but the knight is in the way
so here owen eliminates it with bishop
captures on f6
now the threat is queen to h7 and before
recapturing morphy just
doesn't allow queen h7 so first bishop
to g6
uh kicking owen's queen back queen to e2
now again with
uh ideas of infiltrating with queen day
e6 and now morphy just recaptures bishop
captures on f6
we have queen to e6 with check and now
king to g7
and now uh queen to d7 check so here you
can see that uh
now the situation is that morphe has two
bishops for a rook and uh well
uh owen still needs to develop his rook
and knight so
uh uh whatever owen had in this game is
no longer existent so king to h8
getting out of checks and now queen to
d6 uh going for
one of the bishops so morphy needs to
defend king to g7
and now uh owen doesn't repeat with the
disc 27 uh king to eight trade but
rather he wants to he wants to play so
he starts
developing pieces knight to d2 and okay
with
c captures on d4 morphic grabs the d4
pawn
and now first knight the f3 uh
disregarding the pawn he wants to bring
more pieces into the attack
but now knight the e5 by morphy and now
he's saying
okay now i'm not material i want to
trade queens and also i'm threatening to
ruin your
uh pawn structure here because if you
just trade then first i'm going to
capture with
check and after this i'm going to get a
nice semi-open file for my rook
with my bishop pair against your rook
it's gonna be
well it's gonna be a much much more
pleasant game for black so instead after
this knight to e5 owen doesn't allow
this
even though it's probably his best
chance not to lose the game he
instead goes queen to a3 but i mean
what is the queen doing on a3 really uh
getting away from from all the action
and now he just allows morphe to open up
his king side so morphe does this
without any hesitation i imagine uh
knight
captures an f3 with check g captures and
now d
captures on c3 as the bishop also helps
out with uh with an attack here we have
b
captures and now rook to g8 getting the
rook into the game
he plans to move the king and then you
know wreak havoc along the along the g
file
so rook to e3 not allowing the queen to
to be useful on this diagonal uh and now
king the h8 opening up the h file for
the rook with king h1 by one
and now d4 by morphe and now there's
really not all that much you can do here
uh if you if you move the rook d3 is
coming
uh just creating a pass pawn you can
also just capture on c3
create a pass passport this way so a lot
of possibilities here so owen instead of
uh
just moving the rook he goes for c
captures on d4 but this means he will
also have to give up one of the rooks
for the dark square bishop
so morphy captures with bishop captures
on d4 and now rook
8 e1 you have to give up one of the
rooks as we've said
bishop captures rook captures and now
queen to b1
with check king h2 and now morphy goes
in
with the fancy stuff bishop to e4
playing for the crowd
queen to g1 is the threat of checkmate
and owen needs a good defensive idea
uh so queen to c3 the only uh possible
defensive idea as
you also prepare rook to e1 which will
block off the queen's uh
access to the to the g1 square so rook
to g7 morphe blocks check and now
rook to e1 attacking morphe's queen and
now queen b6 again offering the bishop
uh because if you offer the bishop just
check king has to move and queen to g2
will be checkmate
so instead owen of course has to block
this diagonal rook the e3 is played but
now it's actually
a beautiful checkmate in five for morphe
so feel free to pause the video here
uh and try to find this mate in five
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
second
move of the the combination and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's queen to d6 check no doubt all of
you found this one but the second move
is the
the the beautiful one king that h1
uh owen gets out of the way and now of
course you cannot deliver
queen to d1 chuck because the rook will
block it simply the queen and rook are
able to cover the d1 square
so you need to deflect the rook with
bishop captures an f3 check and that's
it
uh now there is only one move rook
captures on f3 this was played
but now queen to d1 gets the job done
queen d1 check
king to h2 and of course morphe finishes
it off with queen to g1 and this is now
checkmate
so another really really wild game where
morphy shows uh owen who's boss by
beating him again with the black pieces
and without the f7 pawn
so really really incredible stuff uh
like
if you load up these games in an engine
the engine will give you
in the first like 10 moves it's a plus
five plus six for owen but then
a few imprecise moves and it's zero zero
so morphe
uh really really gets it going if you
don't
if you don't just crush him when you
should then you're not gonna you're not
gonna win a game
so we'll see how how the match continues
we're not gonna show all the games only
one of the more interesting ones and
then we're continuing
on to the match with howard staunton or
maybe not we'll we'll see how it goes
uh but yeah that's the game i do hope
you enjoyed it also check out
the other videos in the morphe saga if
you're just joining us and also uh the
link to
chess quiz will also be in the
description below so so do check that
out
uh i would like to thank uh steve boyer
asara al-ghamdi
uh shane somerville barry mcmurdock and
eric novak for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the good
stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day